[Music]
[Music]
I had the pleasure of New York and I
serve the dashing Chloe inside kids well
I really happy with my achievement with
this one it's really great the Roger
dashing world Locrian was in death my
Roger's wife to bring in renowned
scientist Roger died in 1995 at the age
of 57 get a huge presence in impact and
science ranging from high-energy theory
to plan the path integral to this to
studying detecting objects in the oceans
and you'll set a huge impact in their
department
so I maybe might show a balance how many
people you're interacting with Roger so
I didn't but I'm sure that it's made I'm
sure that he would be happy about
today's session and also I would
encourage students and everyone to
regularly attend the o'clock we gotta
find out what's going on in other fields
and to see this energy appreciated so
prior to September 14 2015 which was a
zero
gravitational wave detection era we had
many colloquia here at UCSD on the life
of collaboration from various people
with updates and the common feeling
afterwards was that this was a heroic
effort which probably had a negligible
chance for success in our lifetimes be
aimed to make the most precise ruler
ever built
measuring the motion of a mirror to when
ten thousandth of a proton or less and
it just was hard to imagine what that
could even mean but what they actually
did it and so this is I think a good
lesson for all of us
these kinds of incredible animals which
might take years to pay off really could
hit the jackpot so we're delighted to
have today the Corolla leader of the
legal effort very very shrewd his PhD in
experimental particle physics at UC
Berkeley and he went the high energy
experiments on various fronts from the
early 1960s to the mid 1990s
he was at Caltech since 1963 so we
overlapped there with Roger and he was
the BPI Celtx
high-energy experimental group up until
1996 and then you transition to become
the PI of the lego collaboration in 1994
the director of 1997 and again this was
a heroic effort to keep the dream alive
and on track and funded by the NSF for
all of these years and then four years
ago they actually did it so the
yesterday in the new way to see the
universe by observing oscillations of
the fabric of space-time so very of
course has a years ago I uh I haven't
been here for at least a decade actually
and that's nice to be back I'm gonna try
to be somewhat forward-looking today so
I'm not gonna just concentrate on
showing you what we did which I will
show you but I'm short cut that a bit
because I I want to talk about more
about a little bit at least about where
what we're doing now and where I think
this is going in the in the future so
that you can do that first let me
comment as Ken did that I came to
Caltech in as a postdoc because of
Richard Fineman actually in 1963 and
when I arrived at Caltech Roger - Ian
was graduate student there he came to
Caltech in 1960 as a graduate student
from Harvard
and he was just finishing up when I came
and get the graduate students and
postdocs were kind of around
we were pretty crowded together so I got
to know him right away he was just
finishing his PhD at that point and his
PhD was I don't know what the PhD I
think it was on I know what he was
working on was the mass difference
between the neutron and the proton and
working for Steve for out to you at that
at that point but he was also very
involved with Murray gell-mann and he
got his PhD or finish that work quite
quickly soon after I got there in 1964
and then he was working on trying to use
current algebra which is what murray was
doing at that point to develop a
dynamical theory of hadrons that was
their goal and he worked on various
things quickly on that in 1966 I thought
I was being doing pretty well having
come as a postdoc in 1964 by getting
made a faculty member as an assistant
professor at Caltech only to find out
down the hall that Roger also was made a
faculty member only he was made a full
professor immediately so that tells you
a little bit this was part of the fact
that he was fantastic but also the fact
that he was being recruited from
Princeton along with Steve Adler at that
point and in fact he left for Princeton
and I knew him after that but more from
a distance but during that short period
at Caltech I I was fortunate enough to
know him this picture was taken at
Princeton soon after he left from
Caltech I couldn't find one it at
Caltech itself so let me reflect a
little bit before I talk about LIGO
about astronomy because be a big part of
what we'll do with gravitational waves
after we have tested Einstein and maybe
found something there or that side of it
is to do astronomy in a new way and how
is that going to fit in and where does
it work and I let me just reflect a
little bit on my view as if
sis of astronomy a little bit in the
20th century it'll may be mostly the
last half of the 20th century the big
advance I think in astronomy that's led
to so much information is that we
changed from just viewing optical
Astronomy as the tool to do astronomy to
doing astronomy at all the different
wavelengths everything from the radio to
high-energy gamma rays and of course
we're still doing that having
instruments that are looking at all the
wavelengths and maybe looking at the
same phenomenon for example here are a
bunch of different astronomical
instruments looking at the Crab Nebula
so this is cue it gives us the ability
to of course study the science of these
different objects with all these
different wavelengths and that was a
huge advance I think generally for
astronomy and now we have fantastic
instruments and we'll have better ones
in the future and all these different
wavelengths so that's kind of a lesson
one we've also learned very very
recently this last spring I think was
the dramatic result of this that we can
also do astronomy and gain by combining
instruments together as one instrument
in this case this was using the major
radio telescopes in the world that are
spread around from the South Pole to
Europe and Asia and combine them as one
instrument keep in mind that these were
never made to be put together as one
instrument they have different features
and different readouts and so forth so
it was really a very major effort
starting from something that already
existed sorry to being able to put them
together and from that they brought all
the data together this has been going on
for so long they pointed to a black hole
called m87 and we all saw this beautiful
first image of a black hole that
appeared even
more on that where they call it above
the fold in the New York Times above
Trump that day last last spring so this
is bringing together different
instruments these to me are just kind of
general lessons as we move to what I
think is the next big step and we've
made just a little inroad into that
which I'll show you which is to do what
we like to call multi messenger
astronomy it is don't just use the
electromagnetic spectrum but try to use
any other way to detect things so what
is that and the electromagnetic I just
pointed out we have instruments and all
the different wavelengths the second is
to use something very different that is
gravity our gravitational waves and we
presently have LIGO and we'll have
future instruments that are better and
thirdly we can use particles that come
our neutrinos so the combination of
these in the future is a way to
understand the physics that produces for
example the neutrinos the Astronomy that
may give all the electromagnetic waves
gravitation which is a very different
force and be able to understand whatever
we're pursuing in astronomy that much
more we already have an example of it
which we got from LIGO which I'll talk
about briefly in this lecture but I'm
trying to cover a lot of territory so
now let me go back so we can start from
the beginning for those of you that
haven't ever never seen what we've done
what we accomplished and we'll start
from that and I'll give a kind of brief
history of that we all learned gravity
somewhere in elementary school by our
teacher telling us when we jump up the
earth pulls us down and the Apple
falling out of the tree and so forth and
so on and we even got a formula that was
given to us by Newton and 1680s in the
Principia when he wrote his theory of
what he called unified gravity unify
Universal because basically describes
gravity whether it's the planets going
up what moon going around the earth the
earth around the Sun
tides or whatever else involved the
Apple falling out of the tree that
theory is arguably the most cent most
successful physics theory of all time
but we basically replaced it or have
added to it with Einstein's theory of
gravity which was brought in 1915 so
this is a different theory of gravity
I'll try to give you an indication of
kind of how science develops this
doesn't mean note in Siri was wrong but
what is it about Newton's theory that
had to inspire us knows knowing
something more about gravity which is
what Einstein and a new theory brought
us so the equivalent formula is shown
here which I won't describe in any
detail and but physically it's bringing
space and time into one four-dimensional
unified space-time and this is basically
the idea under Nina underneath
Einstein's theory with that theory we
basically have a consequence which is
gravitational waves and that consequence
basically comes about because of the
accelerations of two objects for example
in what we detected so I'll just pick
that as an example going around each
other like this Einstein showed in 1918
two years after it by the way he
proposed gravitational waves in 1916 one
year after he came out with the theory
of general relativity in that period
where he proposed gravitational waves
he didn't develop it from fundamental
theory he basically just instead noticed
that if he set up the equations of
general relativity in a particular way
they looked like the equations of
electromagnetic waves and I think I'm
going to show that to you on the next
slide and because of that he just
basically made the leap being Einstein
that there must be gravitational wave
since there are electromagnetic waves
didn't prove it this didn't really get
much traction
and the physics humidity first quantum
mechanics was coming in and this was not
a proof of anything it was a conjecture
and he also made a statement that it the
effect was so small that it wouldn't be
detectable of course he couldn't
envision modern lasers and optics and so
forth that we used to make the detection
so what is this theory well if I tried
to formulate it for you I can't do
general relativity in this lecture we
won't finish but if I set it up in a
particular way and just to satisfy those
that understand it I say what I'm doing
on the left-hand side it looks like a
Phil Miller equation that is the
equation of electricity and magnetism
which I show here with a different
symbol H mu nu H mu nu is the
fundamental what's called the strain and
general relativity and it's the
measurable parameter that we measure
when there's a gravitational waves so
this equation for people who know
electricity and magnetism should look
basically familiar looking at that
equation as I say you can read the left
to see what I did set it up that way but
then if I have the equation then of
course it's going to have the same
features this electromagnetic radiation
it's going to have plane waves and two
polarizations just like are shown here
and the strain that little H is the
magnitude and the speed in Einstein's
theory is the one speed he has in
general relativity the speed of we call
the speed of light but it's basically
the speed so it goes at the speed of
light you'll notice in my picture though
these two polarizations are not at 90
degrees to each other
that's because basically gravity is spin
2 and so they're at 45 degrees instead
of 90 degrees to each other and just
like in electromagnetism they're
separable we haven't done very much yet
a little bit of being able to separate
them I probably won't have time to talk
that very much but separating the two
polarizations is completely doable
experimentally we just haven't gotten to
where we've done very much on that yet
so what are the gravitational waves
themselves first they are some some in
his formulation which is a formulation
of space-time they're ripples in
space-time itself they go these ripples
go at the speed of light and the
amplitude is very small so let me just
say where does that all come from first
in classical gravitation yeah in the
classical theory there is nothing like
say the equivalent of a photon or let's
say in this case a graviton so these
waves don't have an accompanying photon
equivalent that we know of so in the
classical theory they travel as just
ripples are distortions traveling at the
speed of light in space itself that's a
little bit like throwing a stone in a
pond still pond the stone goes to the
bottom originally the waves and the
waves which is just part of the water
propagating out of course not at the
speed of light so the gravitational
waves are the same why are they so small
they're not so small necessarily because
of the equations I've shown you they're
small basically if I want to
characterize it by the fact that maybe
fortunately for a lot of other reasons
space itself is for incredibly stiff so
if you think of the wave is like the on
the pond distorting the space itself
space has a characteristic if I used a
Young's modulus or something that it's
just incredibly stiff so that the
gravitational waves just don't distort
it very much that distortion and what
I'll show you is about one part in 10 to
the 21 so it's a very small number which
is the origin of what we have to detect
the effect itself is shown here if I
were to have a ring of free masses and
then the gravitational wave came through
what's it gonna do it's gonna make a
distortion I've said the amplitude one
part in ten to the twenty one so I'll
exaggerate it in the picture and it has
a frequency it's a traveling wave so it
has some frequency what it'll do is to
distort this circle of free masses a
little bit so that it got an elliptical
in one direction and then as the half a
wavelength later it goes toward the
other direction and so it goes back and
forth between making a taller and
thinner shorter and fatter but only one
part in 10 to the 21 a little bit like
going to an amusement park where there's
a mirror that makes you tall and thin
short and fat and you go back and forth
between those so that's what we try to
measure and if the size of the circle or
one meter then we'd have to measure the
distortion twenty ten to the minus
twenty-one meters that's why we make the
thing big so we make it kilometers
instead of a meter in order to make this
number a little bit more palatable and
it brings it up to ten to the minus 18
meters still a one one thousandth the
size of a proton that we have to measure
so that's the challenge and the scheme
that we have is well adapted to that
because it measures small differences in
two different directions what's shown
here is a schematic of an interferometer
I'll show the waves coming in a minute
the waves come you split the beam and
send it to directions if the distance is
the same you said it so it'll be the
same with no gravitational wave when the
two beams come back you set them so they
cancel each other exactly canceling and
in a detector that's shown on the right
you see no signal but if the two arms
change the length a little bit relative
to each other they can add and give you
some signal and that's the fundamental
technique that's used and
interferometry in general as an
experimental physicists we're talking
about measuring an incredibly small
number and we have we know how hard it
is to measure an absolute number we have
a institution that measures the sizes
the weight of a kilogram or the size of
a meter stick and so forth the absolute
size of something is hard to measure but
it's an experimentalist sometimes a very
small difference is easier to measure
we're lucky here and that the effect is
very well suited to interferometry the
only problem is how do you make
interferometry good enough to be able to
do this problem so what are the
challenges if I just simplify them as
much as I can and what we had to do to
be able to do this interferometric ly so
you can see this is a possible technique
for seeing the effect I show the
challenge here with a little H on the
top which is the strain is a change of
length over length that's fine it's one
part in 10 to the minus 21 and we're
going to make the detector in our case 4
kilometers so we have to measure some
part in 10 to the minus 18 that if I
just boil it down gives us two
challenges and they're pretty steep and
difficult the first one is that we have
to be able to measure the interferometry
to one part in 10 to the twelfth of the
wavelength of the light used in the
interferometer so many of you have used
an interferometer and a freshman or
sophomore lab or maybe in something
somewhat more sophisticated and freshmen
or sophomore lab you see a bunch of
fringes and maybe in your lab you
measured something to one-tenth of a
fringe or something like that
and in a more sophisticated instrument
maybe people have done it to one one
hundredth or one thousandth is the
wavelength of the light we had to do it
to one part in ten to the twelfth that
was the first major challenge and
something that we began working on about
1990
and once the idea this idea was solid
and we knew how to compare with another
technique which I don't have to have
time to talk about today the chat first
challenge was can you do interferometry
at this level and through the period of
Oh 1990 to implementing it and improving
it I'm out of time already to 2010 we
developed all the tricks and so forth
which in detail I won't go through it
all to get to a level of ten to the
minus twelve and we were there at some
point
the second challenge so there's two
challenges and I'll show you kind of how
we got at them the second challenge is
despite the fact that we seem to walk
around and everything seems stable the
earth really moves around a lot
and you can't do what we do in the
freshman or sophomore loud in that lab
you went in and there was some sort of
optical table and you took your mirrors
and you X fastened them down tightly to
the optical table if you did it well you
saw the fringes we can't do that because
the optical table on the ground is
moving around a huge amount compared to
ten to the minus twenty one or Timna
minus eighteen meters so we can't have
this whole scheme of being on an optical
table we have to somehow even though
we're here on earth float this
interferometer so that it's not affected
by the movement of the earth of course
we can't completely float it so the
question is how much can we isolate it
from the movement of the earth that was
the second problem big problem and like
you know oversimplify but those are the
two big problems that are be solved to
interferometry at a level orders of
magnitude beyond anything anybody had
ever tried or done and the second is to
actually isolate yourself from the earth
well beyond what people can do so that's
the problems we had to solve and it took
us a while we convinced the NSF that we
could eventually do this
in 1994 and that's when we got the
project approved and at that point we
had to somehow make it work on some time
we developed a proposal that we
submitted to NSF
where we're not allowed as you know
proposers to tell them where to put it
so we instead had what we call sample
sites in our proposal and one of them
was that there were two institutions
before that in about 1990 the NSF
decided there were two groups trying to
develop this one at MIT one at Caltech
and they didn't want to pay for us both
so they forced us into a marriage
together and we started working together
they're very unlikely marriage in 1991
but it's been a successful one despite
the fact that it seemed unnatural at the
time anyway we started working together
in 1990 we wrote this proposal in 1993
submitted to the NSF in that proposal we
put we had a show how we would implement
it isolate ourselves from the ground
everything else so we had one sample
site that was near Caltech actually in
the édouard near the Edwards Air Force
Base out in the desert high desert and
one in southern Maine not so distant
from MIT sound illogical we put it in
the government we're happy because they
funded us but you'll notice they rotated
it by 45 degrees and you can guess why
we ended up with strong supporting
senators in those two states so funding
is not but in case I forget the big
heroes of this whole thing are the NSF
they approved us in 1994 that was one
miracle they stayed with us until more
than 21 years before we made a detection
which is a double miracle that they
somehow through four different directors
stayed with us through this whole whole
not on controversial attempt
so anyway we end up with two detectors
which I'll describe I shall picture them
and I'm in a minute 3,000 kilometers
apart so 3,000 kilometers apart means
the speed of light takes 10 milliseconds
to go from one to the other so if I were
to have a gravitational wave come this
way it would hit and for 10 milliseconds
before this one
come this way 10 milliseconds before and
if it comes down this way they'd be at
the same time which means we set a
requirement that they be coincident with
in plus or minus 10 milliseconds then we
look at off times that is when this one
happens more than 10 milliseconds away
from this one
as a way to measure whether there's
anything that gives signals that are
just happening in the instruments that
give us background and that we do all
the time so that was 1994 this is what
we built you can guess which ones in
Louisiana this is this is Louisiana here
notice in Louisiana this is water the
water table is about a millimeter below
that different dirt and in order to keep
from being flooded we did what you do in
a highway and is built a big berm I
can't see it very well I'm sorry you
can't see it very well in this picture
but basically this part is built up to
about five meters above the level so
they're wandering floods which is not
uncommon the apparatus is okay building
it up to five meters
meant that this part down here was the
borrow pit that we got the dirt to build
it up it immediately filled with water
catfish alligators and so forth then the
local hunters came and killed the
alligators it was kind of interesting
the other one is on a do a side that's
different interest it's on the Hanford
reservation where the reactors were that
were used for separating
in the world way for separation in World
War two and we're way out in the fringes
of that all by ourselves so we don't
deal with as many interesting local
problems they're different problems
institutional problems with it do we
we're out in the middle of absolutely
nowhere they come and pick up our mail
and deliver it so our graduate students
write to their girlfriend
they take those nicely out they'll only
do business mail so how you deal with
the deal to build the site you have to
have water to do anything construction
wise we dug down and the distance we
were told by the civil people we didn't
hit any water getting permission from
the do e on the Hanford Site to go
another five meters deeper was a major
undertaking you can imagine why so
anyway so we put these things together
what are they supposed to do this is a
picture of what is supposed to happen
just schematically what shown is on the
left it is a sensitivity notice it says
H same age and ten to the minus twenty
one on this schematic view is here 10 -
-20 - this is more sensitive going down
so the sensitivity and this is a log
scale down here is frequency so what
Worth firsts sensitive to on the Earth's
surface is where we make the earth the
quietest and that turns out to be the
same band our ears have learned that the
earth is quietest by evolution that is
what we call the audio band we have
nothing to do with audio but it's really
if you go to lower frequency the earthís
is too noisy
and our ears cut off so we don't get
bothered by all that noise and at the
highest frequencies our ears can't
sample fast enough so it cuts off
between ten and ten thousand Hertz we're
in the same frequency band and really
for the same fundamental reasons it's
the motion of the earth so that's the
sensitive a band that's available to us
on the earth I'll mention later what's a
in space so what limits us on the earth
first the shaking of the earth itself
that's shown here is seismic and it
falls as frequency to the fourth power
it's incredibly steep and that's why our
ears cut off it gets really really noisy
and so we have to beat that to get the
low frequencies that turns out to be
absolutely what mattered for making the
detection which I'll show you had high
frequencies were cutoff for the same
reasons as your ear cuts off you have to
sample faster and faster at high
frequencies and so you don't have as
much time you get less signal and it's
the same thing for us we get so many
photons in the interferometer as we go
to high frequencies it's less and less
photons in the frequency band and so
that's what causes this to go up the
middle band is the fact that we we have
an interferometer where we had mirrors
those mirrors are made out of atoms and
molecules and and materials and in that
there's KT noise Brownian motion and so
the motion of the atoms moving around is
basically the limitation and that's
shown here as basically thermal noise
it's KT noise and then all these lines
below are what lurks to beat us if we
manage to move these down far enough
for example residual gas so if we make a
normal vacuum pipe we're pretty close to
where we want to be and that's not safe
enough because we want to make this
better and better and so instead we made
a vacuum system that is an order of
magnitude or so below there and it's
therefore the largest high vacuum system
in the world
larger than the cern high vacuum system
because all of cern is a pure vacuum
system but not high vacuum high vacuum
for us is more than ten to the minus
nine Torr the units that are used for
vacuum and the other problems are shown
here and so the sensitive region where
you can detect gravitational waves or
something that's above
all these basically background issues
and that's where we search so
gravitational waves can come in
something that gives one frequency now
it for example be a spinning neutron
star our pulsar that has a quadrupole
moment or it can be something like I'll
show you which is a in spiral which
basically changes frequency with time
and it crosses this band in time and
that's what I'll show you so we built
this into like Oh our best attempt
we told the NSF from the beginning that
we would yet in the beginning to a
sensitivity we're detecting
gravitational waves was possible but not
probable meaning that we didn't break
any physical laws the gravitational
waves could give us signals but we
didn't know of any sources that were
strong enough to be at that level but we
were way beyond anything anybody had
ever done in the past in the meantime we
would build an infrastructure which is
the main cost that was capable of
improving the sensitivity beyond that we
gave plausibility arguments for how we
could improve it another factor of at
least 10 and asked to be also funded to
develop the technologies that would be
used to do that during the time we ran
the initial version of like oh so this
is the history of the initial version of
LIGO we build it between 1995 and 2000
we turned it on and you can notice it
looks like this shape so this is the
design we came down here this is a log
scale so you can see we started orders
of magnitude from the design and the
design is above where we think we could
have to detect and we ran it made it
work like an interferometer it already
was working better than anything people
had used previously to look for
gravitational waves which are primarily
big bars of aluminum and we would run it
for six months or so
lick our wounds fix things put in
improvements and run it again and this
is just a series of about five years to
bring it down at least on all the
frequencies except the very lowest to
the level here we didn't see any
gravitational waves during that same
period this ring is up to maybe two all
about four or five we did develop the
technology so I'm gonna concentrate on
one because it's what made the detection
we worked on the design the technologies
we would need to gain another factor of
10 a factor of 10 isn't just a factor of
10 that's a factor of 10 in our ability
to measure this little H the strain what
we measure in gravitational waves
fortunately is an amplitude not a power
because we measure the stretching and so
forth so we basically are measuring an
amplitude that means that if we improve
the sensitivity a factor of 2 we look a
factor of 2 further out into the
universe and that's a factor of 8 2
cubed and the amount of stars galaxies
and so forth so our goal was to get
another factor of 10 which would be a
factor of a thousand improvement and
what you get so we have this nice
multiplying factor and we put a major
proposal into the NSF into all four to
do this they approved it and then we had
to stand in line and wait for money for
over five years and during that time I
worked on designing a linear collider so
then they funded us and we built it and
I won't go through all of this we've
changed almost everything better lasers
better optics better mirrors so forth
and so on
that we did I'll skip all that but
basically all inside the same
infrastructure and so the costs is even
though it's very sophisticated was much
less than the original LIGO since
used all the big vacuum tanks the tubes
the vessels and so forth which from the
beginning we designed to be able to fit
what we hadn't designed yet improvements
so I'll pick only one technology and
it's the one that mattered so if you
need the elevator speech to tell
somebody what it took to detect
gravitational waves wake up for the next
two slides that is how did we manage to
isolate ourselves from the earth this is
a pretty simple story so the first thing
is that we do people have developed a
pretty good technique for doing that
that we use every day and that's the
shock absorbers in your cars so what
does a shock absorber in your car do
when you go over a bump and in the early
days cars did that you know what you
know bumped up but instead we put in
this shock absorber in the car the shock
absorbers can't get rid of the energy
it's there but instead it's kind of
squishy and so it takes the bump and
changes it from a high-frequency bump to
a low frequency same integral of energy
little frequency and you just feel
yourself go a little bit over a bump so
why can't we use the same way to get the
seismic shaking in our frequency band
and move it out of our frequency band so
we undertook to make the world's
greatest shock absorbers and this we did
started designing in the early 1990s and
they basically consist of Springs the
springs made out of special material
with just the right cushiness so that
it'll take the frequencies that we care
about and move them to lower frequency
not only that we took four different
layers of them so that what isn't
captured by the first gets taken by the
second the third the fourth however that
all is vertical the earth doesn't just
move vertically and also most
horizontally so to take care of the
horizontal we basically take a test mass
and make it into a pendulum if
hang a pendulum and I move the top it
doesn't do very much to the bottom so I
can move around the top without doing
very much at the bottom and in fact in
order to make this really right our
pendulum was shown on the left is a
quadruple pendulum so that each layer is
from the others and we have controls on
the top three that can compensate and
the bottom one has nothing on it and
it's our test mess that's a complicated
pendulum to do to work with instead of
working with just the bottom one but
it's what we had to do to the horizontal
part in detail it looks a little more
complicated as you can imagine and I'm
not going to talk about that but the
factor that we needed was the factor of
10 to the minus 12 okay so what I showed
you is the when I showed you all those
limits as shown here this was the best
we did with the original version of like
oh the calculated performance if we made
everything work right is this line here
and we could change the optics a little
bit to emphasize the high frequencies
compared to the low frequencies and
that's what the red one is for example
to try to make it better
high frequency at the cost of a beam
some over said low frequency so our goal
then was to make a new version of like
oh that would be factor of 10 better or
a factor of a thousand better and how
much volume of the universe that could
look at and that's shown here this is
this same curve that's over here and the
desire was to bring it down and this is
what we did schematically for high power
high frequency which are limited by is
the number of photons that are in this
thing just statistics they call it shot
noise if you're an ammeter person if you
are a particle physicist you call it
full of statistics but you basically
want to put as many photons in as
possible and then you have to worry
about photon pressure on mirrors and so
forth which I won't deal with here but
you can imagine we deal with that
somehow
at the medium frequencies we have to
have a better test mass to eliminate the
KT noise better material bigger and
heavier and so forth and we did that and
at the lowest frequencies we have to get
better seismic isolation but I showed
you our seismic isolation it was pretty
good so but it was only one part in ten
to the tenth not one part in ten to the
twelfth
so how do we get another factor of 100
in seismic isolation we did that by
taking another mundane gadget that
people use and got regular life that is
most of you have gone on an airplane and
put on these earphones that are noise
cancelling earphones so what do they do
when you go on playing the earphones
basically are picking up the ambient
ambient motion from the engines and
actively canceling that and it gets
quiet and magically the stewardess comes
up and talks to you and you hear
perfectly well even though you've got
these things on so that basically is
doing an active not just a passive job
of canceling what's in the what's coming
from the engines so of course we have
nothing to do with audio but we just
stole the idea again and our problem is
a little bit harder because in our case
we have to somehow sense what has
escaped the passive isolation and
compensate for it actively so what we
did is develop sensors basically seismic
sensors that we buried inside in various
ways I won't tell you how aware inside
this big array of shock absorbers
measure the ambient motion and correct
it for it and believe it or not that
gave us the other the last factor of 100
and you can see that over here if you
look on the right we we were funded in
about 20
ten or eleven as I said and then we
don't like oh the advanced LIGO over
three or four years we started putting
it together in twenty thirteen or
fourteen and we immediate all this thing
we can't make it all work at full power
and lasers and everything for the
beginning so like for initial like oh it
takes some steps to get it all working
but after trying to use the new version
of LIGO for about six or eight months
now in testing we ended up here this is
where we were at the beginning this is
where we are until we tested the two
colors are the two different
interferometers you can see they perform
the same and this is the design so we
weren't there yet this we didn't have
full power in the lasers we didn't have
the seismic totally tuned and we have
some residual noise which takes time to
get rid of all these by the way these
vertical lines are all there in any
sensitive apparatus these are our
resonances that are either electronic
like 60 Hertz multiples of 60 Hertz or
mechanical because any mount you have
says some resonant frequencies they
correspond to about one percent of the
area of the length and we notched those
all out so that's what those little are
there they don't matter for anything
else so we got down to here and notice
that high frequency we had improved a
factor of three so if we cube that
that's a factor of twenty seven and it
would only take us a month or so to
particular two months to make up for all
we had done before and go beyond that so
we decided rather than continued to work
on the technology for another year so
we'll take an intermediate run at this
level notice though at low frequencies
the gain is a factor of a hundred and
that factor of a hundred is the factor
going from ten to the tenth to ten to
the twelfth by adding act something new
the others were improvements a higher
power laser and so forth
this was adding a new technology act
seismic isolation it gave us a really a
factor of a hundred I think I drew forty
Hertz there and at forty Hertz a factor
of a hundred is a factor of a million
and the rate for anything that's at that
frequency so we decided to run and
within a week we saw this so this is the
signal of gravitational waves as seen in
September 2014 2015 2015 and you see the
top one is what's shown is the strain at
ten to the minus twenty one this is one
ten to the minus twenty one plus or
minus the signal gets about that big so
that was a prediction this is going this
way is time is about two-tenths of one
second and the Wiggles are presumably
these two objects going around each
other at higher and higher frequency the
so-called chirp signal which I'll show
you in a minute and it gets as the two
objects get closer together it gets
bigger and higher frequency so if you
look at this these are broader than this
one here it's getting narrower and
taller and we saw six or seven wiggles
and this these two signals came in seven
Millis
luciana and the second one at Hanford
Washington seven milliseconds later the
bottom one i've superpose them on top of
each other and you can see that they
immediately look alike if you shift one
by seven milliseconds which isn't very
much this immediately looked like
gravitational waves obviously and I'm
not going to go through this history
very much I show in the next plot no I'm
not on the right-hand side but data from
the two for the data from the two left
and right and the calculations using
Einstein's general relativity of the
merger of two objects
show you the parameters in a minute of
the two objects and you can see they
look alike and even more impressively if
you subtract the Einstein's equations
from this you get just this Wiggles
which are noise but not no structure of
any kind which immediately is pretty
simple but gives your sense that this
looked like we'd really seemed the right
thing from the beginning just to
emphasize that low frequencies are what
matters this is a time frequency picture
of the same data and you'll notice that
most of the signal is around 40 Hertz or
so we got the factor of andriy so this
was the first detection with that
detection you can actually take these
Wiggles use Einstein's equations and
determine the parameters with quite good
accuracy if you know the shape well so
this is the formula you use to determine
for example how far away it is
determination of therefore the rich if
the spins the rate of the masses and so
forth and it's a second order you can
determine there's another term that I've
left out or you can determine things
like the precession for example and
using them together you can tell things
about the sky location how far away it
is with the orientation is extracted as
you extracted so there's an incredible
amount of information if those
measurements are good enough and that's
what we did and with that we determined
for example for the first event that the
two objects were about 30 solar masses
each one 36 the other 129 that within
three or four four or five solar masses
they merged together the final mass was
62 solar masses meaning that it emitted
about three solar masses of gravitation
of energy and gravitational waves in
two-tenths of a second the brightest
object in terms of energy
in the sky at that point at that point
in time and we can even measure the
final black hole spend for example and
how far away it is this was four hundred
megaparsecs away so that's the beginning
now to be honest that isn't what we
expected events to look like we were
lucky we always thought that we would
not see something that you immediately
know as a gravitational waves wave but
that we would have to pick it out by
sensitive by sensitive measurements in
the noise the technique is what you call
match filtering and I'll describe what
that is in a second first on the left is
kind of how we populate the area of
parameter space that's available to us
so we can see in our frequency band the
merger between objects between one and a
hundred solar masses one can be one the
other one one hundred they can be fifty
fifty or somewhere in between the
different colors here are the on the top
if it's black hole black hole mergers
then you're in that regime and the
bottom our black hole our black hole
neutron star and neutron star neutron
star so those are kind of the areas of
space parameter space that we covered
and we have a noisy environment like
this thing on the right and we want to
see some signal I've just drawn a shape
like a signal and we use match filtering
so how does match filtering work
it basically is shown here looking at
the bottom by multiplying this thing
that's moving through against a template
that you put in here and you see a
signal so we basically and we've most of
the gravitational wave events that we've
seen we identify this way not with a
naked eye like the very first event this
is the second of that joint it was done
with a match filter and in fact this
event which has many many oscillations
even though it's down in the noise the
fact that we
measure it over and over and trace it
was better in terms of for example
testing Einstein's equations in the
first one I only had six oscillations
but was very big so this is the first
couple events I'm not going to talk
about it anymore but just to tell you we
can do it
we use these to test general relativity
so we're for the first time testing
general relativity in the regime that
matters the most
we know general relativity works very
well for example in the week view what
we call the weak field limit but for
practical applications for example your
GPS and your car wouldn't work without
general relativity which is a correction
made and the satellites that travel over
it that's the weak field limit that
works very well there could be
differences from Einstein's theory in
the strong field limit of course near
black holes is the strong field limit
and we don't have alternate theories
that we can can't compare by running
them through the data that would be
ideal instead at this point we look for
deviations from Einstein's theory and
for example we added a dispersion term
which is what I'm showing here is just a
simple example and the dispersion term
would in a limit could be massive
graviton for example would add a
dispersion term the dispersion term
means it wouldn't all travel at all
frequencies at the same velocity it
disperses the signal we put a little we
don't see any evidence of that we fit
Einstein quite well and therefore we can
set a limit on the mass of something
like a graviton which I did here and
it's something like one part in ten to
the minus seven parts in ten to the
minus 23 II V over C squared okay now I
want to kind of move on so we can talk a
little bit about the future too before
we end up what we very much like for the
first version of LIGO we have a whole
set of improvements to get down to where
the bottom line is that I showed you and
we saw the first two events that I
showed you and
we did the same thing we turned
ourselves off for six months looked our
wounds put in improvements and made it
work better and then we ran again that
was what is called the o2 observation
all run - and in that run we actually
observed now and have reported 10 for 10
samples of black black hole mergers
that's starting to give us a sample of
what the different masses are and so
forth which can help us understand how
they originated there's different ideas
where they originated the first issue is
that we've always thought and I still
think that using a totally different
probe to look at the universe we're
gonna see science that's different from
what we see with electromagnetic waves
and that already happened because in the
very first event we saw 30 mass black
holes 30 some 36 and 29 and 62 in the
final version we don't expect that from
astronomers astronomers onand didn't
expect that because the these are
thought to be stellar black holes come
from the collapse of a star after it
burns up its fuel and it's hard to have
stars heavy enough to make such heavy
black holes so now the question is why
where do these heavy ones originate and
how are there regions of the universe
they're depleted enough in heavy
elements so that they're more stable
that's called low metallicity regions
for example is it some region of the
universe is so dense that black holes
when they're smaller hate each other up
and build themselves up or maybe what
particle physicists might like better
maybe their primordial to tell the
difference between those we need to get
larger samples of events and understand
where they come from in terms of how
what their population is in terms of
distance mass Ben are the two objects
cell spinning in any correlated way are
they uncorrelated that's what we're
trying to do is we I get more data so
we're just getting started on that
anyway we published a ten events and it
has this feature that they're much
heavier then we thought near the end of
that we we and I think I'm out of time
pretty close near the end of this we
were able for the first time to do what
I brought up at the beginning and that
is be able to Sky localize well enough
to try to have electromagnetic
complements so we had instrumented from
the beginning to do this and I show you
the timeline here starting from LIGO
itself we have two instruments using two
instruments we can tell something on the
sky to a ring a little bit better
because they have antenna patterns but
basically a ring you need three to
triangulate and the third one for us is
what was our competitor to detect
gravitational waves but now our partner
in terms of analyzing gravitational
waves
that's a detector made by the French and
the Italians in Italy in their piece
called Virgo if we put all three
together then in a time of just a few
minutes we can tell where something
happens and announce it to the astronaut
astronomers and they can take a look and
we have to do that quickly because these
signals don't necessarily stay around
for very long in the meantime to do the
real analysis for us takes a long time
because we basically have to do fits
Einstein's equations do mean Einstein's
equations on computers is a hard problem
and use all kinds of fancy parameter
estimation codes and so forth and so on
so we make a quick analysis online make
mistakes doing that but basically it
gets us to talk to astronomers so this
is the sky localization we got using
just like
- LIGO detectors and it's pretty bad
it's hundreds of square degrees
astronomers don't want to try to and
can't cover anything that will but in
August of that year the second run last
year we added the a Virgo detector and
that allowed us to basically see an
event immediately this is August 14th
2017 to see the same event they didn't
see it very well because they're not as
sensitive but you can see us alone only
did it this way this is down to
something like 60 square degrees still
not fantastic but good enough so
astronomers could look of course it's
black holes so they didn't care but we
were really lucky so we made this work
we were gonna turn off LIGO at the end
of July because Virgo wasn't working
wasn't working and wasn't sensitive
enough they talked us into running one
extra month while they got themselves on
they got on and we did this this picture
was enough to satisfy that we thought
their funding agencies so they could
still exist and then we got really lucky
because three days later by the way all
ten of these none of them have reported
any electromagnetic counterparts not
surprising but they have then on August
17 three days later we saw this event it
was localized with three of them we were
able to localize it to 31 square degrees
and it's close it's 40 mega parsecs away
and it lasted lasted four minutes you're
hearing the signal if you're really good
you can hear the little chirp at the end
which I'll show you this lasted in our
apparatus not four
two tenths of a second but for two
minutes because this is very high
frequency this is the three detectors
it's a frequency time plot and as we get
near zero you should hear a little chirp
signal I'll stay quiet
you can try okay so that's the signal
amazingly we were lucky that we were
there
using that alone by the amplitude we
could tell not with some ambiguity
because we don't have the spins of these
things how far away it was and it wasn't
very far away it's only 40 mega parsecs
away from some other magic coincidence
it turns out that the Fermi satellite
was looking in the same direction for a
gamma-ray burst at that time and two
seconds later our signal is shown here
and coming up this is the Fermi signal
and two seconds later they saw evidence
of a gamma-ray burst in the same part of
the sky over here so this is their where
they were looking this is where we see
counting the Virgo detector inside by
the way I'm really proud of this because
I suffered with astronomers telling us
we can't point well enough for them to
ever do anything for at least a decade
and then the first event ever seen we
did better than they did so so anyway at
the same time within two seconds so this
thing happened within two seconds the
best instrument we have to look at the
gamma ray bursts sees a gamma-ray burst
a short gamma-ray burst and that part of
this guy that got followed up and then
we are credible of course because they
saw something the Cygnus messages were
sent out to astronomers around the world
I think more than a thousand instruments
of one type or another turned themselves
or did what they had to to look at this
guy that's the biggest mobilization I
think ever in astronomy around one thing
it varied from gravitational waves to
neutrinos that didn't see anything
x-rays gamma rays radio waves so forth
and so on those are gonna come at
different times so the time scale is
shown here we are the earliest because
it's a merger nuclear physics happens
and sends out high-energy gamma rays
that happened 1.7 seconds later and then
later you get the depending on what the
nuclear physics is of this coming
together you get the other signals at
different at different frequencies I
showed here at x-rays or radio glows
afterwards and so forth and so on so all
of that was done there was a nice
phenomenological model done by somebody
at Columbia University of what he called
a Killa Nova kill ANOVA we know what a
supernova is a Killa nova is this and
the predictions of the Killa nova based
on one event this is all we have so far
look very good so I just show the
different colors and how they were
supposed to fall and theory versus the
data
it all fits very well my Killa Nova
emission signals are there so that's all
very nice phenomenologically but of
course it's only one event to go even
further with one event we may have
solved an interesting puzzle physicists
always have to tell you the reason for
everything because that's our job and
we've always had a really unsatisfactory
way to explain how heavy elements got
into the earth so where did that gold
platinum and so forth come from that's
in the earth when the earth was formed
we know that most of the universe is
made out of hydrogen and helium so it's
not that most of the heavy elements must
come from stars which work by the fusion
process fusion process starts by burning
hydrogen helium and works its way up
lithium and so forth eventually it gets
about iron and fusion doesn't work
anymore and so that's as high as you go
with fusion at that point the Stars
burned itself out gravity wins which was
pulling in and they
star collapses in you have a supernova
so where did that where do the elements
above iron come from in the earth we
know how they come in the lab in the lab
we've had people who are experts at
making heavier ones and getting the ones
in the bottom of this named after
themselves or something by by bombarding
usually neutrons on a heavy element and
then making a heavier one and that's
what's done so now for the first time we
see a process by remember that's
neutrons and we're talking about neutron
stars so all of a sudden we have a
process or two neutron stars come
together these heavy elements very
compact nuclear bodies are hitting each
other and you can try to calculate then
happening how many heavy elements were
made and people have done that but keep
in mind it's only one event that we've
seen so far and the majority of the ones
we care about the most for example
platinum and gold probably come from
earlier versions of a neutron star
merger that's kind of nice and in fact
in the calculation the neutron star
merger is a tremendous source of gold
this merger that we saw if you believe
we did a hundred earth masses of gold
that's a by the way I get interviewed a
lot these days and the reporters just
love this part of it
now let me spend a few more of my
overtime minutes talking about where we
are and where it's gonna go next so this
shows how far out we can look in the
three detectors that are running right
now today I just took this off one of
our displays last night and what shown
here is how far help we can look with if
we're looking for neutron star binaries
that's kind of our way of telling them
what our sensitivity is and you remember
that one was about 50 this is the
Italian detector it looks at about 50
and the two LIGO detectors which are
different from each other only for a
kind of technical reason of not having
put one feature in one of them that's in
the other one they are about a hundred
and forty make it parsecs our design is
over 200 this is the number of events we
have now we're running on a third data
run I'm not showing that data very much
because we don't do it when we're online
I told you it takes us a long time to
fit but you can see the amount of events
are going up quite rapidly we now have
about one a week that we're accumulating
right now of something you know we
analyze it later to see what it is
however we immediately have to classify
it so this is the classifications and
events that were sent to astronomers
which we have to do within seconds or
minutes from when we detect it we don't
really do a detailed analysis we've
pulled back seven so we've made 33
announcements in 26 weeks seven of them
after we looked at in some detail we
pulled back we're getting a little
better at that they were mostly at the
beginning of the run and then we
astronomers want to know more they don't
want to know just did we see something
and they're gonna go turn and look they
want to know whether it's interesting
for them to look so they want more
information we're not very good at that
yet and we make mistakes but these we
classify as black hole black hole which
is most of them this is from the present
run that's going on black hole neutron
star or neutron star black hole which we
haven't discovered
yeah but as candidate we have a
candidate or terrestrial meaning we
found out that it's just background
noise and these are the ones that we put
out so far only they're not really
identified at this stage that we've
discovered a black hole neutron star for
example which we haven't seen yet it's
just that in the quick online analysis
one of the objects was less than three
solar masses three solar masses is kind
of the magic number or the amount of
gravity that uh an object will have
can't be strong enough to be a black
hole so we don't think black holes exist
much below three solar masses so anyway
in progress we're doing better we're
gonna do better at pointing we're
presently building another version of
LIGO in India they're also making a
version of an interferometer work at the
kameoka mine where the big neutrino
experiment is in Japan and when we put
those all together we'll go from today
which is the upper left-hand corner
those bands are kind of how well we can
see something happened in the sky to
something that looks like the bottom
right-hand corner by about 2025 so we
can point very well to do what I started
talking about multi messenger astronomy
with almost anything we see by about
2025 we also have other sources of
course that we're looking at I'd be
negligent to not mention them we only
talked about binary in spirals of course
there are other sources for example the
collapse of a star supernova if it's we
don't know how much of a quadrupole
moment there will be how non-spherical
asymmetric a collapse is the
calculations are very good so we can't
tell the big computer models that do
supernova collapse basically assumes
fear achill symmetry so they're useless
for us so it's kind of
phenomenologically done but there's
burst signals these are the ones that we
know about there's periodic signals for
example spinning neutron stars in our
own galaxy - they they give radio
signals to the extent that
they're not it's totally circle
asymmetric they'll give gravitational
wave signals and different from the ones
that we see now which are transient once
we see one we can follow it for as long
as we want to measure its parameters and
lastly maybe most interestingly is the
possibility to measure stochastic
background from the early universe and
that's a big goal for the future this is
just to say that we know we're improving
LIGO it's still being improved and we're
working on how to make a better detector
and we're not yet despite the fact that
people didn't believe that we could do
what we've done we're not limited by
nature and we know that we're limited by
our own ability technically at this
point and so we're under progress in
designing the next-generation
gravitational wave experiment and we're
at the level of not having to invent
technologies as much as trying to find
some optimization that it can be
affordable so this is an example of a
study that was done in Europe we have a
slightly different ideas in the US but
we work together of making a triangular
interferometer underground about 300
meters underground where it's totally
quiet the arms are longer than ours ten
kilometers the triangle gives you some
interesting features and the ability to
concentrate on different frequency
regimes most importantly it's cryogenic
if we lower the temperatures which is
not easy to do but run it not at room
temperature but low temperature it can
be much quieter and with a triangular
one we can concentrate on frequency
bands and make it sensitive at the cost
of not seeing the other ones if we do
that in a study here the u.s. one we
call well let me just show you what's on
here this is where we are when we're in
the present design this is how far we
can go with the present sites without
building a new detector this is what we
expect to do with a new detector and
with that we can see for example the
black holes that were observing now all
the way to the edge of the universe
which means now we're seeing
redshifts of nothing and we'll be able
to go to the very earliest times and see
how they evolved with time and I think
eventually the best way to see back to
the early universe is with gravitational
waves because they didn't get absorbed
okay just to mention like astronomy
we'll be able to do gravitational waves
in different frequency bands and in fact
that's underway so in space the project
is called Lisa it's a European project
but NASA will be a minor partner and it
covers instead of 10 Hertz a 10,000
Hertz
it covers 10 to the minus 1 to 10 to the
minus 4 Hertz it's 3 satellites I'll
shorten the next slide that are
separated by a million kilometres and an
even lower frequency is what I call PPT
I hear that's a bad acronym but it's
it's a pulsar timing array looking at
the fact that pulsars give very constant
clocks if you measure a whole bunch of
them and the clocks change time a little
bit it's because the time to get here
got warped by the passage of a low
frequency gravitational wave and so
people have tried to do that now with
you know present instruments and they
can't do well enough but I think within
the next decade we'll see the ability to
do this so by the 2030s a little bit
like astronomy maybe not very well yet
we'll be able to cover a very large band
of frequencies for gravitational waves
this is just a picture of the one of
Lisa and which by the way they've proven
the technologies quite dramatically by
putting a satellite that did the really
hard jobs already in space the hard
thing is you remember I had the free
masses how do you create a free test
mass in space and they show they can do
that in a test flight last year so this
is the ultimate goal I think is to go
back and one tool we have they can go
back to the earliest times in the
universe to understand really what the
Big Bang was all about how particles
formed maybe why we have
matter-dominated universe even the
instrument I think we have eventually to
do that not immediately
his gravitational waves so I think
that's where we are and just like y'all
Alejo sort of things these two guys I
think began well is now the birth of
multi messenger astronomy thank you
[Applause]